whether clubhouse is huge in a year or
not the time you spend here right now
while it's
hot is valuable everything eventually
goes away it's about maximizing
attention and building reputation and
community
while it's hot if you have a question
please uh
feel free to raise your hand let's get
some questions going
hello eddie how are you i'm well where
are you from my friend
i'm from slovenia very nice how can i
help you
so three years ago we starting a
business
and uh from small country and now we are
selling
all over the europe um so we are making
around um
15 millions so um
we are we are selling through facebook
ads and instagram
and we want to to build more brands so
we doing a lot of um instagram
influencer and how can we make um
brands to to make more growth
so you're trying to build more brand
instead of sales dna right
yes yes yes yeah so i you know it's it's
about content right you have to make
content
whether it's influencers whether it's
starting clubhouse
chats there's such a big difference
between building brand
and building um sales and so
what you need to focus on is brand
content right
you need to focus on actually making
videos and pictures that build awareness
and make them hear of your product not
just
click and buy your products so i think
influencer is a good play i think tick
tock is a huge play
in europe so i would get very aggressive
with content on tick tock
where your website or wherever you're
trying to convert is in your profile
i think youtube pre-roll ads that are
brand
not sales focused that are very targeted
between the is a very strong play i
think starting a podcast is a very
strong play
those would be the places i would look
my friend
thank you um very much for your help
you're welcome my friend good luck dylan
hey gary what's going on man life is
good and you
it's going great it's going great for
bringing me up here
um in a world where
you know a degree is still a gatekeeper
of some sorts and specific kind of um
like businesses what would you recommend
for people who
are still pursuing it but don't have the
degree yet so let me give you some
context
so i own a company called my luck
it's a sports psychology company i
actually know dustin because i work with
him
um and just you know we talk some kind
of so that's awesome
i'm still in school but the the context
that i bring to the table is that i'm uh
a former national champion for taekwondo
so i was number one in canada
uh top 40 in the world traveled
everywhere competing representing canada
as the national
captain and all that and along the way i
developed a sports psychology
program based off of you know what i
learned in the industry and what i
learned just from being an athlete
and you know i'm in school now pursuing
the degree but i'm not there yet
and i've you know made a lot of progress
in terms of working with
ufc fighters and football players and
you know some of the best in the world
but i still find sometimes that when i'm
speaking with people
there's still a little bit of that well
you know do you have your masters yet
yes or no and i'm just wondering
it's yeah i got it through that uh
two things um never sell the unsellable
so if you walk into a meeting where
you're trying to convince somebody to
work with you
and they harp on that you convert it
into a friendship karma acquaintance
meeting
not a potential client meeting and you
potentially even cut the meeting short
and then you move on to the next i mean
you are literally talking about
millions of people that could
potentially be your clients and you're
over focusing on the nose instead of
spending your time
finding the yeses and as you know
i would argue that all the conversations
you've had on a bad day it's 50 50 if
people give a [ __ ] versus don't right
i think so too which is why i was saying
on a bad day right so
to me this is a non-conversation
there's too many people that are willing
to work with you without the [ __ ]
paper
as a justification that you
dwelling on it even this question was a
bad use of time already
to that theory my the i've sold things
that nobody believes in my whole life
i need to have a website i'm selling new
zealand
spanish and australian wine i believe in
google adwords versus direct mail and
print
i believe in this youtube show i believe
in twitter
i believe in instagram i believe in
social media i believe in voice i
believe in podcasts i've
my whole life i've been selling quote
unquote
things that nobody believes in sports
cards everybody literally laughed at me
three years ago
right dylan i don't spend time trying to
commence
don't dylan don't spend time trying to
convince oh that's a
that's a that's a non-starter for you it
was really nice to meet you tyrone sally
ricky thompson
move on
yeah you're right like right like what's
the punch line here like
convincing the unconvincible is a waste
of your time
i would get to it early and not in like
a dick way where you're like hey do you
give a [ __ ] about like
somewhere in the first five ten minutes
of whatever time you're committing
get a sense if that's a roadblock and if
it is
i would start a referral business and
say hey you should talk to my
homie sarah she's incredible she is
actually certified
the end yeah you're right and i think
what i do so far is i've been listening
to a lot of what you've been talking
about
over the last couple of years so uh what
i do is i use this stuff for free
right and i think you know yeah but i'll
be but i'll be
first of all i love that but i really
and thank you but i really want you to
get home
on don't do something for free to
somebody because they don't validate you
because you don't have a degree like now
you're just trying to convince somebody
don't convince anybody dylan
all right thank you you got it brother i
appreciate it man of course
i love when this stuff helps other
people as well ross what's good
zayn and tan are my team so we won't be
talking and talk to them enough what's
good russ
yeah what's good man thanks for the time
gary so um
i'm running some campaigns for some
clients i'm the head of social life
agency in the uk
and um they're a very specific niche
client in the tech space
and you know i've seen some of the
reports that we've been getting from
from last month from december and
they're just not good at all and
obviously
i'm coming to them with you know
recommendations between paid you know
targeted stuff niche on linkedin
but is there um is there still scope for
them to use facebook i mean
they have sort of platforms there
available there but
i've just kind of tailored them i've
just headed the approach to linkedin
because i feel that's where they need to
be but you know is there still a space
for facebook and instagram for these
text-based clients
are they is it a sas business or is it a
b2b business
it's like so they're like data like data
analytics
businesses like a very niche sort of
product service no
i think they need to be in clubhouse
linkedin
starting a podcast maybe doing some
phishing on twitter on keywords where
people are talking and they need to
engage as a brand
but but general facebook and instagram
marketing for b2b data analytics
companies
is a is not a best use of strategy
it's a no-go so just completely swipe
that completely because
some of the reports and some of the
results i've seen from the
you know from their facebook stuff is
just so poor so yeah you don't have the
targeting capabilities or the audience
psychology to convert business results
in that environment if you're an sap or
a sales force
there's oracle there's some brand
rationale to be in those platforms
but from a short term business results
you're talking linkedin
and becoming an original media company
podcasts host clubhouse rooms
you know very narrow niche [ __ ] like
that
sounds good one more thing
two things for you ross one i've decided
recently somewhere in the next
decade i'm going to write jab jab jab
left hook
and uh and then number two uh
vaynermedia london's growing rapidly so
keep that in mind
good cheers
hello vanessa hello gary
uh first of all uh sorry for my english
i'm portuguese
and my english is not perfect your your
your english is much better than my
portuguese so it's an honor
and i want to say that i'm a
truly fan of you uh i love your work i
love what you say
your thoughts and
i'm i'm here i i it was a surprise for
me
to be here uh i'm new in this platform
i just want to ask what do you think of
clubhouse uh do you think it will
achieve a level
as instagram or facebook
i think clubhouse is incredible and the
concept
of what we're doing here is human
it's what people do in real life they
hang out in halls of conferences
at dinner tables so i'm very bullish on
this format
the the thing that's gonna play out
is is this a feature or is this a
platform so i think
twitter's already testing a competitor i
predict that
facebook and instagram are going to
create this as a feature
most people have their audiences on
those platforms
and will have their own self-esteem
in wrapped up in the fact that when they
go into a
talk on instagram there's 2 000 people
in it
and when they go to clubhouse if they
start a room there's eight where they
don't even have an invite
so vanessa i think clubhouse has
incredible long-term upside
i also think that um that it might be a
feature
okay all right okay thank you you're
welcome but vanessa if you're asking the
question
and this is for everybody here from the
perspective of is this
worth your time to spend time here
most people don't understand that
question well let me explain
right now this has a lot of attention
and has a lot of very
intriguing people in the community it's
a good use of your time
whether clubhouse is huge in a year or
not the time you spend here right now
while it's
hot is valuable and most people worry
about it going away
everything eventually goes away it's
about maximizing
attention and building reputation and
community
while it's hot yeah yeah got it
yeah got it cool thank you you're
welcome bye-bye
hi may or may how do you pronounce it
hey gary good morning hey real pleasure
pleasure is entirely on on this side of
the phone i am a long-time listener
long-time disciple and i'm a little
giddy right now so
i am coming from an immense place of
gratitude the amount of
premium content you've delivered over
the years is incalculable
and everyone here right now in this
room is um is wildly valuable i'll i'll
keep it i'll keep it short i'm known to
be a bit loquacious so i'll
keep it i'll keep it tight do your thing
meg gary
i was a you know what i should change
that i
am a internal corporate planner and
was unfortunately laid off early in the
pandemic
from my dream i
landed an internal corporate physician
at a biotech firm in cambridge
massachusetts
we were doing brilliant things in the
event space
with with some pretty healthy budgets so
um
as you can imagine um i was able to
travel the country travel the world and
deliver some stellar
programs um unfortunately i was laid off
and and
understand that um decision and
after throwing um about two weeks of
a deep pity party for myself and for
what my industry was suffering i took
the leap
and and larry um gary you're a big
big part of this i started a small
boutique
virtual events firm because you saw the
knee yep
to pivot immediately and so really kind
of capitalized on that
that white space that dead time where we
were all just kind of shell-shocked
and super lean super super lean hadn't
done any
paid advertising really leveraged all of
your tools
utilizing social linkedin facebook
and it's a miracle story but somehow
howard stern's admin found me on
instagram
and long long story short i designed
produced and delivered howard stern's
first ever
virtual holiday party that's amazing
good for you
it's it's brilliant and and i offer that
up
not as a is it braggadocious um
more of a of a nibble of hope for for
anyone out there
um the internet the internet is a
platform of opportunity
you know period and the story
is may is there anything i can answer
for you yes
yes let me bring it home i feel like
this
miracle story is is just that and
it and it is almost bringing to life
everything that you preach
i mean it truly is it was a i i worked
quietly i worked
patiently i didn't tell anyone what was
happening during the summer
and then it paid off i am curious if
there is a way i feel like i'm not
leveraging the story because i
feel like i'm sitting on something here
you just need to do what you did the
first time you need to put out content
around the story
you need to go to linkedin right now and
i don't know if you're a good writer and
write
you know six paragraphs of let me tell
you a story
of a coveted layoff right you need to
yes
i did i actually posted and again you
will find inspiration by you about being
candid and vulnerable and
documenting the process i posted a story
and i titled it a series of events
i love that title mate let me tell you
something do you know many times i've
told the world about my lemonade stands
and sports card story
i know because i've heard them a lot
right so i think where you might be
getting caught
and a lot of people get caught is i
think you need to tell the story in
written video and audio form
every day three times a day for the next
98 days dm7 you got it dm
every single events podcast even if they
have 41 listeners
and go on for 30 minutes and tell the
story and ask them for the video footage
and then chop it up and then post it on
your instagram write another linkedin
article
more around being laid off during covid
because that's more of a title that will
get
organic reach like this is just reps
what you basically just said to me is
gary
right now you just said to me gary i
have not been eating well my whole life
and thursday i ate clean and worked out
i'm like that's good may
now let's do it for the rest of our
[ __ ] life
for sure got it absolutely cool for sure
have a great day gary thank you have a
great day everyone
kayla how are you hi gary good morning
i'm doing well how are you
i'm well thank you thanks for having me
the first question
is around imposter syndrome and being
a young professional and wanting to
pivot my career i'm in sales and wanting
to pivot into
a more marketing realm and just how to
combat imposter syndrome
by realizing that imposter syndrome is
actually just a fancy word for
insecurity
yeah like and then saying i'm insecure
because these life events this is how my
mom or dad rolled
this is what happened to me at 12. this
is my dna because i'm like my grandma
and then saying cool that's life comma
nobody's better than me i'm just i'm
just
authentically candid of like i want to
be in marketing i want to take my
at-bats
when somebody says no to me that's not
bad it's actually
understandable i'm going to try 113
times
somebody's eventually going to say yes
and then i'm going to try
when i'm trying oh crap this company
didn't set me up for success
i quit or they fired me and that also
doesn't mean i suck or i can't
i just need to go back to the well
because that's only one example of me
getting
at that self-esteem and self-awareness
are the two biggest things that i
actually speak about in
a million different ways and so kayla
literally impossible sir jeremy yep
hello yes i'm here oh good
so impossible syndrome is just a
it's kind of like perfection right it's
an excuse
and not a bad excuse it's a it's a
packaging
it's a merchandising to make something
palpable
you just have to recognize that you have
insecurities about this jump
and that's super okay i have
insecurities about
being on top of tall buildings i had
insecurities of kissing girls in high
school like
everybody has insecurities right and so
that's cool
but it's not going to change whether
it's going to be
good or bad or indifferent what it is
going to do is make you not do it
and you've got to realize much like
swimming or riding a bike or kissing
someone or making love for the first
time or all the things that we all go
through in life
we make them scary in our head and then
they're not scary
after you do it
awesome thank you does that make sense
kayla yes
it does like like do you have a sense
like does that land like you're like yep
like that's like like do you get that
i do because i definitely think it's
rooted in
insecurity right and so somebody told
like you know i don't want to go
into like cry session but like it you
know maybe somebody told you your whole
life that you weren't good enough or you
couldn't maybe society maybe your mom
it's that's you know that's just life
that happens to a lot of people that's
the reality of it but you have to
realize and for everybody here all 2000
of you right
this is very important if you think
you're [ __ ]
or you're not good enough or you can't
that was somebody else putting that in
your mind
like like it's actually just genuinely
not true now that doesn't mean you can
do
anything but you need to try because you
actually don't know
you know what i mean caleb hi gary yes
sorry i
yeah i definitely i agree 1000 it's just
kind of
going deep into like what's what's the
worst that can happen kayla they say no
you're not good enough so you go to the
next person it's no different than dylan
earlier
right right thank you i appreciate that
i hope you have a great day listen we
really really really
have to get into a place where we look
at no
as a motivator not as a indicator
to us not being good
cesma
gary how are you my friend how do you
pronounce your name my friend
original pronunciation i go by simon
simon got it simon it's a real pleasure
yes yeah it's a pleasure to
to be here i really appreciate you
having me i
i very much look up to you i am an
immigrant from poland this was actually
not poland you know we're pretty much
from
very similar region in europe so uh
i've been looking up into your story and
i'm very um
grateful that i was able to follow it
and that i am able to follow it and
then we have the internet so i have a
capability to follow it
thank you so uh i had a chance to be
in the room with you i saw you at the
fairfax uh conference when you were with
uh tony robbins
great experience thank you uh but
what i wanted to say you know uh and we
work with the ergonomics design
and how to pretty much position body
ergonomically
at the computer and i'm kind of going
into many different areas
uh in my life we've been kind of
grinding with my wife my wife as a
physical therapist we've been doing that
for
many years now and uh i guess my
question is i'll go right through the
questions so i don't need too much of
your time
no worries uh what's the best way
to approach gamers and incidency healthy
lifestyle and
basically uh start to direct them into
the position that they
start forgetting about health outside of
the gaming itself that's smart
i think that's actually a really good
idea a niche around health
like physical health lifestyle from an
eating and exercise standpoint for the
gaming community is a really good idea
given that they sit all day
um it's content and reaching out
it's producing videos audio written
words on the 10 platforms that matter
and then it's sending direct messages to
10 000
you know 10 platforms 10 000 direct
messages right
make content for as many platforms as
you can whether that's one or
ten preferably ten but that you know
takes time and talent
and then reach out to people and say hey
i love your i think you're incredible at
twitch or i love your call of duty
skills or your 2k is this or this that
the other thing
but i really think you should check out
this video and maybe you send them the
best performing organic youtube video
that you've put out around the subject
matter
the whole world is based on content and
outreach and distribution and awareness
yes i agree we i've been reaching out
much more right now since our
concept changed since we've been uh
going much into office corporate
economics
actually i actually communicated at some
point with your hr people
that's awesome so i couldn't get to you
that's awesome
right the fact that you got the sky at
vaynermedia
who gets bombarded by my fans 3000 times
a day
means that you're well on your way just
make a lot of content
that's awesome that's awesome
no worry simon real pleasure i wish you
well
um matt mark before i go to you real
quick i need to uh
say happy birthday to my main man caesar
who i just brought up here
an incredible uh part of our team gary
family worked with us for several years
caesar what's good
i love it man happy happy birthday what
is it your 20th birthday
what what what birthday is it actually
for you
good for you brother how you been you
good
everyone's great brother i just want to
say happy birthday i have to go in four
minutes so i'm gonna try to get to
mark and renee i love you we'll talk
soon
mark okay cool thanks for the
opportunity
uh gary love your content so i'm gonna
keep it
quick thank you so much
i'm a freelancer working for the
prescribed brand right now
and like i want to do i'm thinking about
doing a podcast or a clubhouse like
i would love to have your perspective
you said you should do your podcast
on clubhouse i believe that clubhouse is
rolling out a recording feature
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna do my
podcast on clubhouse interview one
person
let everybody listen script the audio
and then put it on my podcast
awesome thank you for that and one more
question
brother i would love to be there the way
i travel is basically twofold
my business objectives for vayner x or
when somebody puts up the big
six figure bag to have me speak so
hopefully one of those two things will
happen
all right brother talk to you soon take
care renee
i can't even say my name in less than
four minutes so i've got to make this
video
i love you okay so what we have is
um pivoted wedding show producers for
30 years we were starting to pivot to
become digital marketers before the
pandemic
that pushed us over the edge we have
found that since we were business owners
and you know working for our own
companies um doing it
following you for seven years doing
everything you were saying little
mini gary is what we were and we were
you know making it work and sale
pandemic came we have found now as we
did
as we pivoted with our marketing company
we found that we
are really best suited to be fractional
cmos
and so we come back with a whole list of
perspectives
and we've got we've got the age we've
got the prowess we get it
we come in and we see things from cracks
and crevices
and how do we attract that client
linkedin content to your face falls off
renee
like literally unlimited content that
says do you need a fractional cmo
another article is do you know what a
fractional cmo
is another one that's titled like 13
ideas to help your marketing this year
and it's just a good piece of content at
the bottom it says
are you looking for a fractional cmo
this is what we do
just go all in on that i think it's a
real
to us oh we want space leads we want
more leads we go and find out if we can
fill the funnel all freaking day
but guess what the whole we did a video
on youtube called
do you have a sales funnel or a sales
calendar correct people are losing them
all
left and right linkedin is linkedin
is your holy grail and host some rooms
in here literally call it
fractional cmo life and get 40
40 people show up because that's how
clubhouse works so content
in business places preferably linkedin
and clubhouse
you got it all right you got it take
care
everybody i'm sorry a little bit short
this morning i was going to go on at 8
30 which is the
a.m which is the time i'm targeting to
go on with these tea with garyvees um
gotta go to a meeting right now but
couple things one
if you take a screenshot of this right
now and hit me up on twitter with a
question
uh in written form i will try to answer
some while i'm in meetings on zoom all
day
uh number two if you have a question and
you want to
have me answer it on my social medias
videos video yourself right now asking
your question
post it on twitter with the hashtag
askgaryvee my team will look for good
questions
and then i'll answer some and you may
show up on my instagram where i'll tag
you and
you'll end up with a hundred to five
thousand new followers so
um those are two things that i can
continue this conversation with based on
my
schedule i hope you enjoyed it i would
love for you to also use the hashtag
uh you know askgaryvee or tea with
garyvee both work for me
on twitter and give me some feedback on
this format and i hope you have a
beautiful
beautiful wednesday cheers thank you
everyone bye-bye hey guys thanks for
watching my little session here on
on clubhouse trying some different stuff
with content i hope some of those
questions uh
brought you some value i really like the
don't sell to the unsellable so many of
you are wasting so much time trying to
convince
instead of going to the next person
who's already interested huge waste
of time content content content content
content content
and many other tidbits i hope you
enjoyed it see ya youtube watcher what's
up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon